ils disent que personnage de ria par
exemple les familles en valeur on a un
extrait pour vous le montrer dites nous
si vous pensez que ça voilà ça mérite
une polémique il ya même alexia laroche
joubert qui est venu s'expliquer à la
radio ouais je vous le dis donc tu sur
wii réduit le prix d'une émission après
émission donc la main fait plus rien
donc c'est le plaisir de nom mais sa
voix la bataille alors qu'à droite il
énerve est une boule je le connais a
laissé partir garde au nom mais me dis
pas que c'est déjà fini
si tu veux une telle dit pas mais c'est
déjà fini
bon j'espère que ça vous a plu les amis
n'y rien et moi on vous dit au revoir
allez on vous laisse à lui les poteaux
marmaille nous on va se préparer et se
préparer pour coire bas pour revenir ici
t comme un guide alors que j'ai à peine
24 ça va être juste un gadget ou les
amis alors les chéris donc voilà donc ça
ça crée une polémique tout ce qu'il ya
une autre
il ya une autre personne à quel
personnage de loulou qui est la bonne
copine elle elle arrange tout elle n'est
toile cuisine et donc ça ça dérange et
aussi parce que voilà la femme aux
fourneaux donc et une polémique sur les
minikeums est ce que vous comprenez quoi
alors moi déjà j'ai toujours détesté je
trouve ça tellement ringard mais la loi
donc été trouvé ça complètement ringard
et alors là on est au delà des clichés
et des stéréotypes
alors il yad'un côté là donc ça vous
énerve aussi banni ça m'énerve ça
m'énerve pas je trouve ça nul est ratée
en fait quoi ressemble au clic aux
clichés la télé réalité on amène à
l'excellent réalité on réponde aux codes
de la téléréalité la saudrune et qu'ils
ont mis tout l'argent dans les meilleurs
helvètes et rien pour les autres surtout
ce à quoi je pensais bas et c'est pas
drôle c'est pas bien écrit c'est pas
bien fait mais un cliché s'il est drôle
si c'est drôle de le fed montrent les
clichés ça permet aussi de lutter contre
ces clichés contre ces caricatures que
sauf que quand c'est pas drôle va du
coup ça tombe à plat ce problème est un
gâteau c'est toute mon enfance les
minikeums donc j'attendais ce retour
avec impatience
effectivement c'est raté mais pas parce
que ces stéréotypes et il campe des
personnages donc pour pour que les
personnages soient identifiés et
identifiable il faut qu'il y ait un
trait de personnalité que l'on méritera
par conséquent c'est comme ici on est
tous des caricatures y en a un qui est
plus marrant qui est plus con je suis
pas là
un titre le nord j'ai raté ouais
j'aurais appelé ça les mini tub et
d'état oui j non mais c'est honteux
franchement et france 4 va mourir et là
tu as raison il faut très vite retourner
ces deux personnages féminins c'est du
machisme caisse est destiné aux enfants
quelle image de la femme vont ils avoir
une qui est pense qu'à se faire belle et
à commérer et l'autre qui aurait en est
réduite à nettoyer à tous la vérité
parce que je crois sincèrement si tu
crois que les négoces et les femmes et
les hommes ont attendu les mini comme
pour avoir une fin une image stéréotypée
ou pas de la femme ça a été complètement
à côté de la plaque écoutons choisi ces
combats moi honnêtement je m'en tamponne
le coquillard mais laura ne m'énerve
qu'ils avaient mise à mal et moi je suis
moi je vous rejoins je crois qu'on s'en
tamponne également d une force
non